teen Ceremony this afternoon celebrating
the expansion of the Southern Nevada
Veterans Memorial Cemetery Mary Jane
beliesza takes us to Boulder City with
how the community is reacting
the Southern Nevada Veterans Memorial
Cemetery is the second busiest Cemetery
of its kind in the nation and the much
needed expansion couldn't have come at a
better time welcome to the Southern
Nevada Veterans Memorial Cemetery
currently there are over 50 000 veterans
laid to rest here and this expansion
will add over 5 000 burial plots and
eight crematorium walls William
pearlmutter the chairman of the Southern
Nevada Memorial Cemetery advisory
committee says support for the expansion
has been overwhelming not too long ago
they're running out of space for the
veterans so with the grant being
presented I would say it's been about uh
three years in the making three three to
four years because they knew we have to
look toward his future for expanding the
the cemetery a big crowd was on hand for
Wednesday's groundbreaking ceremony
including State leaders and Veterans
like Robert benchko the cemetery is
personal for a lot of people it's
personal for me I have a lot of fellow
veterans that I've buried here in the
cemetery is very pleasing to see that
that God has taken a step forward to
expanding and supporting the veterans in
our community as you know from around
1990 till present day we've gone from
280 000 people in the Las Vegas area to
over 2 million now so this cemetery is
necessary and it's it's just a big
Shrine for everybody
a five million dollar VA ground will
help pay for the project which is
expected to start in just a couple of
weeks